[Music]
you know what I think you have to be
your own words advocate definitely not
me either Sam or I'm going to win I
change that Tony's gonna get drunk face
is going to just laugh and not pay
attention Wednesday's not gonna pay
attention Scott's gonna take it too
seriously and he's going to like wear my
glasses look into his eyes it's not even
a question if you could fit right here
second place first loser could be anyone
[Music]
let's worry about Stan style very
reckless and you can never really tell
what he's going to do I think Scott's
gonna win not because she's wearing
glasses and has been so he's he's
obviously taking a pretty serious sam or
Tony Kendall think that you can win and
talk really beginning then it won't work
okay because one time at a soccer camp
in high school I won and doesn't last
month a Confed oakhurst I feel like I'm
going to ride that winning streak
[Music]